on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin à new moore je
suis né baptisé de rente ai
je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre nouvel
épisode du petit amir la semaine
dernière nous avons fait un point sur
les répétitions en appréciant tout le
travail accompli
cette semaine nous vous proposons de
partir à la découverte du métier d'art
thérapeute à travers le portrait de
marica notre méthode en scène sa journée
commence au centre et lindor de sainte
suzanne où elle va animer une séance de
danse avec des personnes en situation de
handicap
avant de commencer la séance deux élèves
viennent se confie à nous ingrid prend
la parole en premier
elle connaît marica depuis 2002 elle
avait alors 11 ans est revenue elle a
fait intervenir le moins c'est pourquoi
la peinture aux oies pour mauvais
tableau
pour moi on peut s'améliorer avec la
presse
les gones est aussi on trouve le théâtre
bois découvrir d'autres états et la
danse
elle m'a mené aussi des gouttes en
métropole à l'air ronald zubar pas
nulles audika est attentif avec nous
m elle nous elle nous écoutent paraboles
les questions connu de monde et voir il
découvert plein de choses avec à vérone
dix commandements des je pouvais faire
la danse c'est vrai j'ai un peu d'air
avant les mouvements thème de vol mais
je me suis adapté par un pot 1 de manga
m'a fait et je sais vous vraiment
proposé de faire la danse du rebond main
sur le cas au bon moment robot du vin
jaune
elle veut devenir rien les jeunes avec
un même si elle est plus trou à la mange
tous mes membres de boue vol
c'est ensuite au tour de kanye de nous
livrer ses sentiments sur ce que marica
et la rue d'en apporter que je suis là à
voir lui faisait de la plastique
maintenant je fais la danse déjà à la
base moi j'ai grandi je croyais pas que
juste le châble fait la danse mais a
montré vraiment c'est pas parce que vous
n'ayez fauteuil qu'on peut pas faire
grand chose
c'est fort sa préférence pour une chose
même si nenê fauteuil balkans c'est une
personne guy très gentil elle nous
indique moussa et même si on n'y arrive
pas trop j'ai apprécié mes bons marca
mais 1 6 2 merci de me faire découvrir
la scène parce que je pensais pas que je
je resterai au revoir
après ces confidences place à la danse
et aux répétitions avec des moments de
grâce qui s'enchaînent
en
sous aaa
mais la cantine
inspirez-vous un peu de la musique
commencez à vous lever à danser un peu
plus avec l'autre
et voilà on va faire comme l'exercice
difficile c'est les traversées on va
faire l'exercice pour tout le monde des
traversées à 3
ma
non